Marines they kill people just for fun
now we've all seen Avatar and we all
know how Hollywood likes to portray the
American military but who can blame them
after all anyone who joins the United
States military is most likely an
uneducated dummy who had no other
options save for prison Layden's for
Bazin but what if I were to tell you
that the United States military is not
only the greatest peacekeeping force
that the world has ever known but has
contributed more to humanitarianism than
Hollywood or the UN could ever hope to
right now we've all seen the tragedy
that has struck Haiti and our hearts and
prayers truly go out to the Haitian
people but while you and I sit back and
talk about the death toll or the fallout
from this disaster the United States
military is already in there bringing
these people aid faster than you and I
can say James Cameron is a Nazi as a
matter of fact by Monday January 18th
10,000 troops will be stationed in Haiti
to help with relief efforts of course
with more on the way
what you mean
ain't gonna be doing any killin from
rebuilding Europe post-world War two to
sending nearly three million pounds of
relief supplies into Southeast Asia
after a devastating tsunami the history
books show us that when the world needs
help the US military is there if the
United States were really hell-bent on
raping throat world countries for their
resources as liberal Hollywood would
insinuate Haiti would be a give me
fortunately for the rest of the world
were the only evil empire who have given
far more than we've ever even thought to
take see folks if you're in the country
that's in dire straits and it looks like
there's no light at the end of the
tunnel you're most likely praying to see
the face of an American GI on the other
side of it so when you think of the
American military and the Hollywood left
wants you to think of this take some
time to remember that in reality it's
more like this
actually it seems the only thing at
which the United States military does a
poor job is telling the world about what
a great job they do so god bless the
troops and god bless the people they're
helping right now in Haiti we're all
praying for a swift recovery soon oh and
if the words god bless offend you just
just go away please go away go away go
away and never return
you